On a déjà parlé des coups de soleil mais il y a une autre très bonne raison de faire attention aux rayons l'été
Oh oui! Le genre de raison qui peut facilement vous gâcher une journée
voire vos vacances
voire votre vie. Tout l'été DTC vous aide à éviter les pièges et les dangers qui menacent votre bien-être et votre santé
DTC partenaire de votre été de votre été. Alors
l'insolation et le coup de chaleur
ça vous parle je suis sûr que oui parce que c'est des mots que tout le monde connaît mais qui regroupe en réalité un certain
nombre de choses dont on n'a pas forcément conscience et notamment le fait que ça peut être mortel
Pour planter le décor l'insolation au sens large du terme
c'est à la fois le fait d'exposer quelqu'un ou quelque chose au soleil et les effets
de cette exposition. Dans le domaine de la santé
évidemment c'est un peu plus spécifique mais on va voir ça plus tard et un coup de chaleur c'est une grosse augmentation de la température
du corps causée par une exposition
à la chaleur mais pas forcément au soleil
une insolation, un coup de chaleur
c'est quoi? Une insolation c'est l'ensemble des troubles qui apparaissent après une trop longue exposition au soleil et quand je dis
l'ensemble des troubles il y en a
vraiment pour tous les goûts. Oui parce que non seulement il y'a plein de répercussions très différentes sur la santé mais en plus leur gravité
ça varie d'un pet de lapin
à genre un pet de Gérard Depardieu
C'est le plus haut sur l'échelle du pet c'est l'équivalent de 9 sur l'échelle de Richter si vous voulez
les troubles en question ça va des coups de soleil aux attentes au niveau des yeux
dont on a déjà parlé à la déshydratation aux maux de tête aux vertiges
voire à la perte de connaissance et dans les cas les plus graves ça peut même aller jusqu'aux troubles
cardiaques les reins peuvent être sévèrement abîmés des convulsions peuvent apparaître et ça peut même aller jusqu'au coma
ça fait cher la sieste au soleil alors le coup de chaleur lui il apparaît qu'on vous restez exposé trop longtemps à une
température élevée parce que votre corps il n'arrive plus à réguler sa propre température interne
qui monte qui monte qui monte du coup l'organisme est en surchauffe et ça il aime pas ça
ça commence par un coup de fatigue avec parfois un peu d'agitation vous avez mal au crâne la nausée
des crampes vous ne supportez plus le bruit ni la lumière votre pouls et votre respiration
s'accélèrent et tous ces signes peuvent s'aggraver et aller jusqu'au coma
voir pire. Comment éviter
l'insolation et le coup de chaleur? et oui comme souvent le mieux c'est de régler des problèmes avant qu'ils n'arrivent
alors pour éviter à la fois à l'insolation et le coup de chaleur voilà sept règles à respecter
quand ça cogne dur et qu'il fait très chaud. Eviter de rester trop longtemps au soleil
par exemple si vous faites une sieste mettez-vous à l'ombre et assurez vous que vous allez y rester en vous demandant dans quel sens le
soleil va tourner. Portez un chapeau ou une casquette de couleur claire de préférence
pareil pour les vêtements et choisissez des matières qui laissent circuler l'air. Buvez 2 à 3 litres d'eau par jour
de l'eau hein
j'insiste parce que l'alcool ça aggrave les choses. Mouillez vous la tête et la nuque à chaque fois que vous le pouvez et mettez vous au frais régulièrement
rafraîchissez les pièces dans lesquelles vous vous trouvez avec des ventilateurs
si vous n'avez pas la clim évidemment. Ne faites pas d'efforts physiques intenses entre midi et 16h
là où ça tape le plus et de manière générale
évitez de vous exposer à ses horaires là. Faites tout particulièrement attention aux personnes vulnérables
comme les enfants les personnes âgées ou les gens qui ont une maladie qui les fragilisent
et quand c'est trop tard on fait quoi? Que ce soit dans le cas d'une insolation ou d'un coup de chaleur les deux priorités c'est
rafraîchir et
réhydrater pour la rafraîchir le mieux dans un premier temps c'est de déplacer la personne dans un endroit frais idéalement avec des linges mouillés un
peu partout autour du corps
genre ses vêtements si elle en a ou encore mieux des draps si vous avez ça sous la main
si elle est consciente n'hésitez pas à lui faire boire régulièrement un peu d'eau fraîche mais pas glacée
attention si elle a des troubles de la conscience si elle est dans le pâté comme on dit communément
laissez tomber elle risque de s'étouffer et elle a vraiment pas besoin de ça et si elle est carrément inconsciente mettez la en PLS
Vous vous souvenez comment on fait?
Et surveillez la dans tous les cas appelez le 15
même si vous avez un doute la personne que vous aurez au bout du fil
déterminera qui il faut vous envoyer s'il faut vous envoyer quelqu'un et surtout elle vous dira quoi faire
voilà DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui on se retrouve dans deux semaines pour une nouvelle vidéo spéciale été d'ici là
prenez soin de vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout
portez vous bien bon sang de bois